hey everyone
sketch here coming at you from 343
industries in redmond washington welcome
to our live stream we're excited to be
here today to give you a first look at
halo infinite's network co-op feature
coming soon to a pc or console near you
uh before we get too much further i want
to take a moment to introduce some
friends from the studio that are joining
us here today guys welcome uh we'll just
go down the row here if you want to take
a minute please who are you what do you
do and uh thanks for being here awesome
uh i'm john mulkey i'm the campaign
design lead uh for camp for campaign for
uh halo infinite and have been leading
up the efforts to bring you guys uh
campaign co-op and mission replay so
we'll get a chance to take a look at
that today
hi i'm isaac i'm the engineering lead
for all the stuff that monkey just
described nice uh and i'm ron brown and
i'm just happy to be here i mean i am
the studio's quality of life program
manager here at 343 industries uh
helping out helping people make helping
people be happy while making halo words
are hard
i i hear you're also a crack shot
throwing fusion coils which is really
yes that's why you're here today right
chaos today me and fuchsia coils are
going to be like this all right we'll
bring some paintings into the video john
elway all day uh so we're gonna jump in
just a second before we do i thought it
might be useful for folks who maybe
haven't been through this before or
maybe are a bit newer to our community
a little bit of context first uh as you
may or may not know uh network co-op is
a feature that we're gonna be releasing
via a flight
this is uh
basically what's the best way to
describe a flight isaac for folks who
maybe don't understand or aren't
familiar with that terminology so what
we're looking to get out of this one is
a technical test of all of the
networking aspects that might not have
been
exercised from the multiplayer stuff
that's out already there are a lot of
unique aspects to campaign we want to
make sure that it's all going to work
smoothly at launch so the flighting
process is basically uh think about it
as its pre-release software it's not
really quite an alpha or beta because we
put it out there and you think about it
moves through
so to kind of rewind we started working
on this feature internally once it's
ready we go out to our first flight ring
which i believe in this case was really
just 343 employees ourselves we took the
build at home we played it
isaac and team and the test team get a
lot of data and information back they're
allowed to able to respond to that
identify issues identify things they
want to improve once that works done it
goes to the next ring which is a bit
larger and in that case it included some
of the folks in one of our community
insider programs we also then brought in
microsoft and xbox employees kind of
kicked the tires again if you will had a
chance to identify potential issues and
opportunities to do more improvements
and then once that work is done it then
moves into the final phase which we call
really just our broader insider flight
and that's where we are right now
to give you some additional context
once we have that build ready it gets
handed off to certification which is a
process that software has to go through
before it can be released on the xbox
platform and the flight build that we're
going to show you today is actually in
that certification pipeline right now so
we hope that the flight will go live
tomorrow but it's a fluid process and
part of why we do flight is to identify
and discover potential issues to be able
to react to them and fix them and
obviously we want to make sure before we
put a build out into any halo insider's
hands that
it's a good experience it'll be
worthwhile to your time and also allow
isaac and john and the teams to get the
date and information back that they need
to really dial the feature in before it
launches so um
if we get updates on that before the
stream's over today we'll let you know
but it's going to be very transparent
we're tracking towards tomorrow but we
are still working through that cert
process and their job is to identify
things that may be a blocker at that
case so
we'll see how it goes with that said
we have the build already because we
know some folks
i want to give my usual caveats this is
obviously pre-release software and this
is not released yet so a lot of great
work has gone into this via those prior
flight rings but just wanted to be up
front about that also for folks who may
be wondering i think all four of us
today are playing on xbox dev kits um
but of course
co-op itself is cross-platform
including xbox 360 xbox series x and s
and of course pcc yep
that's a 360 though oh i said it
question yeah sorry oh you didn't you
didn't get that memo we're going all the
way back
sorry i'm not ready for that good
quality wait it's the xbox one family of
devices
delayed yeah um and actually too
for folks who may be wondering how do i
get in on this flight how can i be a
part of it um there's two answers if you
already have the halo infinite campaign
yourself which means you either
purchased it or you're an active xbox
game pass subscriber if you're on
console all you need to do is download
the xbox insider app and opt into that
and once our flight goes live you'll be
able to go right in access the flight
download the build and enjoy it if you
want to be a player on steam there's an
extra step where we first require you to
be registered on halo waypoint as a halo
insider and that enables us to then pass
you a steam token that you'll then use
to download the build
i do want to be upfront though if you
haven't already done that halo insider
step
that ship has already sailed for this
flight so we'd still love to have you
for the future but it's it's too late
now to be a part of the steam fight if
you haven't already done that step but
as far as i know for the console
once the flight's active you could
actually pick up game pass or buy the
campaign at any point during the flight
and opt into the insider app and still
join at any point so it's a little more
flexible there so without further ado
mulkey you are our fire team leader
today
you're going to be our sherpa as we
explore zeta halo i'm going to turn it
over to you and we're going to kind of
bring our teams together and you're
going to walk us through
how this flow works and how we kick
start a coop match
sure sounds good so one of the things
that i was going to talk about a little
bit was um how the front end flow works
and then also how the combined and so
how the game state is basically
constructed so as an example if you go
to my screen
hey there we are
uh if i go to campaign and if i was
going to start a game i can go down to
load game i'm an excavation site i could
choose this
um you can see that i was playing on
normal like i set my difficulties level
here like just like normal play normal
campaign play sorry um and you can see
that because i'm lame i only have one
skull um i could activate the skull and
i could launch into the game but uh
let's go ahead and have everybody join
in and demonstrate demonstrate some
stuff
find you here real quick
you can see down in the bottom right
hand corner you can see my my fire team
assembling i think everybody's in yeah
right okay cool so now if i go back and
try to start the game now as fire team
leader and i go pick my save this is
maybe something to talk about right here
it's like um one of the one of the one
of the things that we we set out with as
far as the goal goes is basically
everybody being able to play their
campaigns together um so rather than you
know like games of the past where it's
like you know isaac's going to come over
and we're going to play co-op or we're
going to play co-op network co-op and um
uh we would play my game um or play his
game and then whoever game you're
playing is the person who's actually
getting the progress and the other
person isn't we wanted to change that so
that everybody playing together always
makes progress and you save that
progress whether you're playing in co-op
or you're playing on solo
both
so
here i've chosen my save slot and now
you can see over here on my skulls i
have the combined skulls of all of the
team members that are in my fire team
which is great so i can we can
show off you know hey i brought this to
the i brought this to the game i brought
this to the game that kind of stuff we
could play all this together which is
pretty cool um so i'm going gonna go
ahead and choose that as my save slot
and the furthest i've been in the
campaign on this particular save is
excavation site so when i hit start
co-op
the other team members uh you can
probably see their screens if we go to
four there we go um they're gonna pick
their save slots you can see that you
know conservatory let's see we'll go
back to that one screen
yeah this is just basically saying what
you just said right letting me know that
any missions completed any collectibles
gathered any items unlocked by all
members remain so for all of us which is
super convenient
so on this screen you can see the
different players you can see what their
furthest mission is so we've got
conservatory we got pelican down we got
excavation site and we got another
person in conservatory so the way that
this works we're we're referring to it
as no spartan left behind um the idea is
that uh we are anything that we've all
completed um is still completed
everything's completed but um we're
going to look at what is the earliest
mission that not everybody on the team
has completed and we will start at that
mission and so that ensures we're not
going to do any sort of sequence
breaking in the the campaign
you're not going to be playing something
that you have no clue as to what's going
on because you haven't made it that far
in the game and so you can catch your
friends up and uh and level each other
up so you can see that our starting
mission is going to be excavation site
and uh
that's where we're going to go to yeah
we should also just note really quickly
for folks who maybe are watching today
but haven't played any of hill
infinite's campaign
obviously you're going to see some
spoilers potentially nothing major but
you will we are going to play the game
which will include some cut scenes as
well so just fair warning you might see
some spoilers that you may prefer to not
see if you're holding off for the
eventual release
all right take us away let's load in
oh yeah
so like do i have to pull my full weight
or can i just really slack be good if
you were a team player yeah okay nah i'm
not gonna do that okay
i mean at least i was honest about it on
the front end i'm not i'm not going to
be able to okay yeah we'll carry you
yeah just put me in the backpack swaddle
me
just level me and carry me to the goal
that's all i ask right
well good news is there's four of us
right but maybe bad news is mulkey uh in
co-op there is a little bit of scaling
that occurs where it's just it's not
quite as
easy as it would be if you're playing
solo right there there is um in co-op um
there the enemies um their behaviors are
gonna be changed they're going to employ
different kinds of uh
aggressive and defensive behaviors at
different levels than they would if you
were just playing in single player and
then that scales across a starting
cutscene
that scales across the uh
skills across the uh the number of
players so if it's just two players
scales by a certain amount certain
things are changed and if it goes to
four players it's even more so the
challenge feels more appropriate to the
number of players
i also like to call out uh honor rules
for the fire team here right folks so
any one of us could skip a cut scene at
any point so it's just a good etiquette
to check with your fire team before you
uh
jam the button and and
oh you know i forgot i saved i have a
safe state with no ammo so if somebody
sees any uh
friendly fire is on too so right yeah
watch those coils run
[Music]
me i would i would never we have enough
to worry about with the bandage you'll
you're being ridiculous i would never
where's the fusion coil though i mean
asking for a friend
me i'm the friend
oh oh it was brutal i i think that's my
favorite part about co-op is that i
could get to see all the cool stuff that
i've been doing to people all campaign
long but i get to watch somebody else do
it i'm like oh that's what it looks like
from the outside that's amazing all
right what is happening all right there
we go can i i've done nothing yet so
people watching my pov i apologize i
find ron wait wha why why are we finding
me home
i had a coil i was gonna bring it to you
in case you needed one you know what
just trying to help i appreciate that
friendly fire look if you're not gonna
be
a part of the cause
let me know because we can we can wreak
so much chaos together i found some
coils ron
and see me i'm over here playing the
objective like a loser i mean i'm like a
good citizen i'm working on enemies i
got coils oh no i got coils oh it's time
for the coil oh that's already been
collected it might be where it's so
everything's so chaotic but it could be
something to talk about
there's this uh
this uh i've got this data pad up here
that that you can see is not active it's
because everybody in the team already
has it if just one person didn't have it
it would be able to be collected um and
that way you know anybody on the team
and a co-op team can collect those
things and make sure that everybody gets
it right like this one if you want to go
to oh yeah there's a screen there
all right
then we all get credit for collecting
that one
nice
nice thanks for that isaac another thing
here is is the uh the uh the ammo crates
um the way that the ammo crates are set
up for co-op is they also have a scaler
so
uh anybody can use them and there's more
ammo in them depending upon how many
number of players there are so it helps
to support uh support multiple players
i'm gonna push the button yeah i need to
come up and
catch up to you guys okay
and then anybody can i think we
mentioned this anybody can dismiss this
whoops
socially moderated all right well the
rules broken we could cancel whenever we
want ron i think you're now you owe him
a fusion coil i'm just saying yeah you
know wait which one is he no he's the
chief isn't it oh wait let's talk about
that let's talk about it we're all
chiefs
let's talk about that why do we have
four chiefs um one of the reasons why we
have before chiefs is that we made the
decision it goes back to what i said
earlier about uh everybody being able to
play their own campaigns we made the
the the the decision that we want to be
able to play our campaigns together so
it's not like it's a playing co-op is
not like a different
fictional construct it's the idea that
i'm playing my master chief story you're
playing yours and we're getting to play
it together which is really really fun
but when i go back to my solo campaign
it's my master chief story um and so the
thought is that you know we're all
master chief playing our our master
chief stories
um
i don't know if we're even following the
objectives right now i'm just trying to
find right now i think if i could
stop if anything is moving i'm shooting
it i mean with the exception of y'all
one of the fun parts of uh our our sort
of halo unbound you know partial open
world kind of approach here is um in
co-op we can split up so you know this
particular mission it has the idea that
there's two different sides of the the
the uh the the poi the point of interest
that we're at um where objectives have
to be adjusted have to be uh have to be
accomplished geez words are hard um it's
hard to play and talk i know it is it
really is and then yeah i don't have any
issue with it i don't know what your
problem is
uh so you can split up you know it's
like a pair of us can run off and do the
one side oh i got killed um can run off
and do the other one side while the
others are doing the other the other
objective
um another thing maybe to call out
because i just died is uh we're using
the multiplayer death cam system so if a
member dies you can cycle through your
buddies and uh and see what they're
doing while you're waiting to respawn
when it's safe to respond i just wanted
to demo that real quick so i died oh
good thank you thank you that was really
nice
yeah honestly i feel like i'm just gonna
run away from the party to demonstrate
what happens oh this is another fun
thing oh no no y'all know i should have
no way i'm getting shot at
oh nobody helped me in co-op if you if
you uh
if you grapple hook your your buddies um
it will actually fling you like you'll
get thrown uh
harder than you would come here
otherwise it's pretty great i just want
to try something
it's a pretty great way to learn
oh okay
i grappled into a suicide grunt i tried
the thing you told me and it immediately
led me to a suicide grunt
targets no those are the risks that
should have always been safe i trusted
you oh get out of here that's mine you
you failed me we got one pylon down
oh man they're bringing in
reinforcements oh jeez i'm dead
stop dying get more you really want to
demo that death cam a lot yeah i do i do
it it is a nice it is a new feature so
oh that's a shade turret help where are
oh i just did the same thing you're just
kidding me
i saw the red dot on the radar and i was
like i'm killing that today okay we got
one pylon left
oh i don't know about your uh i don't
know if our fire team leader is really
being a tactical genius here i'm not
like it's not just it's like this is
like we're just running around willing
it's a free-for-all chaos what is it oh
i still keep my weaponry though it's
working though it's true
i do keep my weapon oh my gosh
one more
they're not protecting the conservatory
very well
just saying
i know one thing that we had some
questions about after our blog a few
weeks back was uh just sort of how far
apart can we get from each other and how
does that system work i feel like we're
kind of demonstrating that somewhere
right now
i don't want to be in this background i
want to just have a run
right here hey ron why don't you try to
go awol nah i'm i'm i'm not listening to
you i'm out
i'm the i'm the captain chief now okay
i'm the new i'm the new wow i'm really
i'm really far away from you i'm running
away from you i'm serious
i've got peanut butters and jellies i'm
really running away from home i'm i'm
completely serial
right now
so as ron as ron gets far away you just
keep going right as far as you can
considerably far away you keep going the
mission is still happening without me i
is that ron okay so ron if you look at
ron's screen he's got this this
messaging that tells him to return to
the fire team and shows him where to go
not to blossom me hey ron could you pop
up your attack map
okay so that we can show how far away
you are
so you can see that
he's really far away from the rest of
the team members there
um so the the
the area that you can you can cruise
around like that is pretty pretty
generous um and the
the point of that there was you know
that it's it's a it's a co-op game you
know we're looking for people to play
the the game together it's not a a
four-person mmo so you know the thought
is to stay together and work together so
if ron continues to go farther away
whatever man that map does not have any
effect on me uh he basically he's
pushing his luck he's gonna go awol and
be shot
wait
we're going i got a great still going
guy in this son
he's still going yeah
climbing the mountains climbing the
trees no i'm too far from the fire team
i'm getting a warning message now oh my
goodness
wow this is descended into chaos
yeah that's the range yo the unsc does
not even do a court martial man they
just take you out so you can see it's
pretty generous so we wanted to make
sure that it's generous enough that you
know if you're going after some sort of
a mission you can you have the freedom
to to flex and go all around and do what
you want to do and separate as as it
needs to be for doing that mission and
also for flying vehicles you know it's
you're you're gonna be in some flying
vehicles you want a bit of a bit of
breathing room to be able to to navigate
oh here comes some friends um
considerable distance of weight and go
from there so are we ready to uh the
mission on i can disable
uh execute executing
oh jeez
he seems friendly this guy's one of my
favorites
there's just not much room to maneuver
here
by the time i get to the battle he's
going to be very dead huh
well you're
didn't you get respawned back by us yes
that's one of the things
when we do these uh these narrative
sequences here um it uh it uses the fire
team leader as the uh the the puppet
they call it in the
experience but then it brings the team
together uh oh shoot i just
look at that
that's my bad well you wanted to play
legendary what yeah yeah coiled it took
out at least two of us
i had a clear shot and it had to do
and someone jumped in front of it oh man
i get smacked
wait i'm running away i don't
all right shield's down
go okay i'm coming out keep him
distracted you could you can't restart
until the encounter is over
safe oh boy oh i'm back i'm back i'm
back
that's cool you're back i'm dodging help
somebody come help me he's trying to
kill me
how did i die oh my god me i just died
too i have no i had nothing to do with
that i'm out here trying to survive one
of y'all run away so we get just spawn
back what did ron do i'm dragging him
away i'm no i am fighting him i'm out
here playing my partner isaac's mopping
up he's got this he's got this oh no my
skewer's empty help
run away
grapple out of there oh yeah i guess i
do have grapple huh
here he comes helmets
oh my goodness oh jeez
no pressure all right we're back we're
back
we're coming to help oh thank you we're
coming to help all right good i'm gonna
get up
he's he's after me like i owe him money
we got him we got him bring him a coil
direction nice job i will take that
trophy yeah yeah yeah it was never a
time haha there was never a time i was
afraid of you
this is mine
all right
yeah congratulations
um
let's let's let's try something
different
let's take a look at so i'm opening up
the tack map
and you can take a look at this is where
we're at excavation site everything
looks you know similar to what it does
in campaign um normal campaign uh let's
try
mission replay what should we replay
um
what do you want to replay
we could do foundation
let's do foundation where's foundation
there it is pretty good so if i go over
to foundation you can see now that in
the uh the uh
uh
words
the uh the pain that shows the the info
pain thank you but goodness the info
pane shows um all the information about
the mission but now there's a new thing
at the bottom for mission replay so i
can go up there and i can choose mission
replay and when i do it will give me
some options so here you can see it says
if you choose to replay foundation you
will not lose progress in your recent
your currently active mission excavation
site uh if you want to later later want
to resume excavation site from your
further save point you can select an
attack map and choose resume so
we wanted to make sure that there's lots
of safety here where if you want to go
off and do cool stuff and replay things
and all that kind of stuff you're not
going to lose any progress and you're
going to be able to continue what you're
doing so this is a nice safeguard
against it and then one of the other
things that we do here is we give you
the opportunity the now because you're
going to go put this into replay i want
to replay it at a harder difficulty
level i want to put skulls in place you
know that kind of stuff so i'm going to
change the difficulty level to heroic um
because ron said i have to turn on
birthday parties ricky bobby i didn't
this had nothing to do with me and we're
going to turn on birthday party because
isaac says we have to well yeah now that
one that's definitely facts that's just
facts
but i was like yo so in this case you've
already got the collectibles on this
mission but
if any of us missed them good chance to
go back and find the skull you may have
missed or data pad or something like
that right right yeah here we go
you mentioned i was going to say that
was that was unexpected there was a
there was a pause there that we weren't
expecting to see
here we go so this pulls everybody in
you know to go do this mission replay
and i'm going to skip through some of
the cinematics
for two reasons
expeditious
you know getting to the to the gameplay
but also spoilers for anybody that's
watching that might not be at this point
yet yep
well also since we're replaying all of
our uh all of our players have seen this
mission already right
but i'm thinking the people online oh
sure
i'm still waiting to see see one of
y'all uh
do the coil oh yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm
sorry i was i was on coil duty and i
started playing the objective
how dare you how very daryl i dare you
you had two jobs run as far away as you
can and died
look it goes against my get good uh you
know initiative that's who i am on the
inside i get good and i play the
objective so
i'm gonna i'm gonna
drag us around some more so uh if i open
up the tack map again
i want to show a couple of things so now
you can see the icon over this has this
really sweet little like spinning going
backwards in time kind of thing that
means that that mission's in replay um
and you can see here this gold marked
mission with the the spinning and the
pulsing that's our that's our last main
mission that we were in and i can resume
this one right now if i want to which
should i yeah it's madness
let's do it so we're going to resume the
mission now you'll notice that now we
have this other option where we we
started doing a foundation and we
decided to go away from it i can now
resume foundation because we put it into
a replay state
which is pretty great so we could go
back and we could do uh dig site we
could finish that one and then we could
decide you know hey you know we found
some really cool weapons let's go back
and resume foundation and bring those
weapons with us and take out the bad
guys all that kind of stuff so you you
constantly get this opportunity to make
different choices but always be able to
get back to what you were doing which is
pretty great the other the other thing
that's um that's just a part of the rule
set is uh if you
if you change the if you uh quit the
game anything that was in replay just
reverts back to its last previous
completion that way you never are in a
situation where you lose uh progress um
also you can only have one mission in a
replay state at any given time so if you
do already have a mission replay and you
say i'm gonna go replay some other
mission the one that you had previously
there will get reverted you won't lose
any progress and then you'll be able to
play that next mission
it's a lot more complicated than one
would would think at face value just let
us replay missions it seems like you you
all really put a lot of thought into all
the different scenarios it was a it was
a it was quite a design challenge um for
sure and um i think that you know when
i'm when i'm explaining it it might
sound a little bit complicated but um in
practice when you're when you're going
through it it it it does feel really
intuitive which is nice and that's what
we're really hoping to land on so here
we are again so right back where we left
off exactly
so the next thing we would do is
[Music]
turn off the drill
there's been so many names during
development
sweet
take that let's see what's down there
who's boss
okay so we can now descend into the next
mission if we want we could go resume
that mission that we had in replay
um let's take a look once again at the
tacmac
attack that i'm going to open it up um
and
kill an hvtc
bulkarius
okay so i can set a waypoint marker um
in the level and uh if you go look at
isaac's screen he can show what it looks
like in game can you see the marker up
above
500 meter
the fun thing that you can do because
the main reason that you have co-op in
any sort of game is to grief your
friends
um so anybody can go to the tack map and
change the marker remove the marker push
it all around whatever you want to do
nobody would do that i don't think so i
don't think that's anything anybody does
games
i'm upgrading my grapple shot gotta get
that
i did not think
so you know when you're playing campaign
one of the fun things to do is to you
know you find the uh the spartan cores
and you can upgrade your your equipment
and uh
uh the way that we're handling that in
the game is that uh
sorry i'm distracted now i can't play
and talk at the same time um the way
we're handling that in the game is if
you've got
if there's a wait am i throwing in there
if there's a spartan car
[Music]
too much wait for it
oh god i failed that's hard
it is difficult all right i'm going to
do the laser we're going to try it again
i'm going to wait until you guys are far
enough away that i died wait i have to
grapple it yeah that's what i was trying
to do here we go here we go wait are you
throwing or am i i'm grappling i can
throw it all right
i'll throw it really i'll try to sew it
more straight up and over your eye all
right here we go
uh-oh it's over your head
i mean he lobs the fang
wow
you're supposed to catch it with the
grapple easier said than done i never
said i used my face like a normal wood i
mean
all right still making our way towards
that waypoint yeah yeah i'm going the
opposite direction so that i get killed
and sucked too you guys wow that's real
lazy i messed around actually i think at
this point
i don't know
i messed around too much we're getting
the fireplace
let me go back to the update um upgrade
things so uh if you go pick up um
the if you go pick up a uh spartan core
to upgrade your equipment um that one in
the world will
remember that you picked it up but if
someone else didn't it's available in
the world and anybody who activates it
it's given to everybody who didn't have
it if you already have it you don't get
more spartan course so that way it's not
necessarily something you can like you
know cheat and mine for um
hello so anyway that's all tracked
i just heard we had a question can you
grapple teammates oh yeah yeah i was
showing that earlier you if you do it
it's actually kind of great because uh
you get extra momentum just launches you
right and it really launches you so you
can you can kind of uh
go through that there we go
you can uh kind of leap frog through the
world uh pretty quickly that way oh yeah
i'm like a regular blitz launching
myself through the air here
oh god oh god they're shooting me with
with with all the weapons you got to
shoot we got that i've already know that
they were shooting back what what level
is this he's pissed you're the one that
called him out ron i yeah but i didn't
think he was gonna like shoot back they
didn't tell me that he was gonna have
guns as well have you played halo before
you might not have heard of that
actually it would explain a lot of
things about why i'm so bad at this game
oh oh somebody hit me back i'm all my
grenades
oh man y'all just gonna let me get
killed
y'all's gonna let me get killed
oh man he's just right there oh he's
he's down oh we got him let me just come
over here and check him out real quick
yeah he's fine i gave my life full cost
sweet we did it
all right so now we all have access to
the upgraded mangler even if we go back
to our own single-player games
yeah good call i almost didn't pick that
up
you actually don't have to pick it up so
when you kill an hvt there's the the
weapon that's in the world that you get
for that um and you can take it right
then and go use it but then it is
automatically when you complete the
mission added to all of your fobs
so that you can grab it from your fobs
that's good because i took the weapon
that was there i definitely grabbed it
and said oh man i'm trying to shoot that
core and a coil out of ron's hands you
can and then if you'll take a look it's
like oh i did it
sorry john that's fine
that's that's the fun that's hostile
work environment that is the challenge
with doing these man it's like you're
going through and you're trying to talk
through you know the features but at the
same time it's it's fun you know so
that's cool
um so you'll see now that like uh
belcarius we've completed it and now we
have we can fast travel to it now
because you can fast travel to anything
that you've completed and we could also
go mission replay it immediately if we
wanted to um and try it on legendary um
so there you go how would you hurt us
like this
what do you guys want to do next
uh outpost
want to try an outpost yeah sure do a
replay of an outpost
sure
tisha is pretty hard
i mean
not that's nothing's impossible for for
the coil crew coil crew that's who we
are now let's do forge of teach that one
that one's a pretty serious outpost and
having four players on that would be
pretty fun all right
all right oh yeah i did though i did
enjoy forge so you see it gives me a
nice reminder there of like you know by
the way remember you can go back and
take up where you left off if you want
to
not gonna lose any
progress uh-oh
you did lose progress i lost progress
how'd that happen
um
the joys of
pre-release software and live streams
all right we'll wait for our fearless
leader to get back here with us in a
minute i mean i guess
i'm curious
don't don't don't wait for me ron
whatevs
look i died when i left so i'm just
saying you know
i think it's only fit
i am curious who is who would the who
the fire team leader pass to
will you find that out on the uh the
social screen okay
uh john would you like us to quit out of
this session so we can
sort of reform the fire team and go do a
how are we doing on time yeah let's do
that i think we could still take an
outpost out yeah absolutely um yeah that
would be cool well and maybe that's
something that i mean
something to call attention to um you
know
obviously we had you know something we
weren't planning on happening where i
dropped but um
the uh the way that the mission or yeah
the way that the uh co-op emission
replace uh works in the game you have to
form up your fire team and go into the
game together as a fire team because the
world state is based off your fire team
and it's based off the saves that you
choose so um we don't we don't support
like a join in progress kind of uh
participation so if you do want to
change the number of the people that are
playing you have to go back to the front
front end
and uh rejoin uh and enter the game so
that the game state can be set up
correctly all right let's get you back
in the game then
uh we all on the fire team yet no oh i'm
the fire team leader oh that's trouble
so you are the captain of all of you
i didn't do that
all right let's join back up
i think we are
getting close yep
one more
i think we're all in okay sorry i was
distracted i saw our image and i was
wondering if joseph was going to be
jealous of my socks
of course he is look at those beauties
okay now you'll see conservatory is
uh my my save because we finished uh uh
dig site and conservatory is the next
one in the in the line which is great
i guess we'll stay on heroic right sure
and um i've got to do this yeah or else
isaac's going to be upset
it's the best why would he
he's not wrong i know he didn't you know
i wasn't claiming he was wrong just okay
so has everybody picked their saves
no no
it's not that we we do that yeah oh next
next step you're right there we go there
we go all right pelican down i'm okay
with that thank you
sweet so you'll see that conservatory is
now listed as our starting mission
and uh we're ready to go let's do this
[Music]
all right
and here we are at the beginning of
conservatory i wonder what the banished
are looking for down here
let's go find out ron immediately has a
coil in here how did he do that hey
that's like he just carries that quest
is all right the coil is a part of me
that's who i am on the inside oh i guess
this would be another thing to talk
about is um
throughout the game you acquire there's
there's parts where you acquire new
equipment and um if a player already has
the equipment um and they play a mission
that's previous to where they would
normally acquire that they'll already
have it um we don't take things away
from you that way um but players who
have not got to that point yet they
don't have it and so when you go to
these locations and you pick them up
anybody who doesn't have the equipment
now gets it uh but it has no effect on
anybody who already had it or if they
had made upgrades to it or anything like
that so it protects you once again from
things you know
uh
progress being lost or anything like
that
that's a nice hammer you got there uh i
stole your core why why are you like
this you could be better and you just
don't here i'll throw it back to you
where are you no no no no this is
playing i don't want it
[Laughter]
this this is why this is why i hang out
with y'all this is why that's why i'd be
out here soloing isaac or john did you
guys you guys had kind of crazy
surprising or uh unanticipated things
happen over the course of
just working on co-op and once when some
of the co-op shenanigans that maybe you
didn't anticipate or didn't expect to
see no everything's gone by the books
it's been totally
totally boring everything just fell into
place
i think you might be pretty happy about
it my favorite would be like physics
bugs where characters get flung through
the air in
unexpected ways it's always good blooper
material
with we do have
we legitimately have a tag that we put
on bugs which is the blooper tag right
so that we can
save them for later we'll have to do a a
uh compilation video get it out if we
don't play the benny hill music over it
i don't want it yeah sacks
i feel like you know the hardest part to
just be getting people to stay on task
it's too hard to not start chucking
uh yeah it's not a blooper if uh you're
trying right right true oh man i got
shot we still haven't no one's managed
to successfully uh
catch a coil in midair with a grenade
either
i'm sure the community will do it
instantly and
immediately
oh man oh we're going down yeah yeah
i'm hiding here in the corner okay cool
all right we're back
i'm just like a respawn beacon i'm just
going to hide over here we appreciate
that keep keep focusing the fight
okay
sometimes the true secret is to run away
so that your teammates might join you oh
i need to we need the
uh seed
come on oh man
oh yeah yeah i'm carrying coils i can't
do i can't do stuff like that okay
one of the the fun things that we did
during the development of this when
you're putting
the seed in the
the question was can you throw it ready
and get it into the thing here we go and
the answer is no but you go so my
grapple i can't oh it blew up off the
roof jack navit
i can't help how hard i throw all right
i'm here in the gym like i'm doing my
best all right i'm gonna throw from from
the bottom floor here we go here we go
wait why don't we all hold on they're up
there fighting oh wait there's combat oh
they're trying to save the galaxy you
guys are drinking around we're just
playing we're back here playing catch
there's a
there's a thing we supposed to do uh
okay i got it
i died
well if that's what you got i'm so far
away i am the safe spawn you guys are
you guys have no problems
john's
my new my new strategy is to blow up all
the cores as i go through so ron doesn't
have any to mess with uh why are you
like this
don't make me use gunshots this is a
first person thrower and you know it i
still want to see somebody catch one
though i'm i keep trying to give you all
just not as easy as it seems what if i
throw it toward you do you think you
could grapple in fast enough time
i'm getting too aggressive could i do
that probably not could anything most
people sure
i mean
if you don't believe in yourself
thank you you get it done all right
right as i die thanks i needed that word
some inspiration thank you well you're
welcome i'm here for you be the change
you want exactly this room is uh giving
us a bit of a hard time right now it's
giving you also a hard time i i'm just
getting to it so you know maybe if y'all
had help is everybody using the mangler
that's hilarious yes
that is
[Applause]
i just ended up with it somehow i'll mix
it up a little bit i'll grab
that bulldog
they coming in the sides
oh man only i'll hold that plasma for me
get out of here
oh man i got a little bit aggressive
there
a little overreach
sometimes you just gotta throw your body
out yeah i saved you guys it's like
secret service i just took that bullet
it was amazing
you got all the seats yeah i got the
second oh you did okay okay good because
i accomplished no objectives i've gone
from playing only the objective to
playing none of the objectives
ages of chaos
where's ron
oh
i didn't know what to expect i saw
danger coming okay
i ran away like anybody smart would do
[ __ ] a coil at you i played way too
much multiplayer to see somebody just
[ __ ] a coil in my direction and
saying catch let me stand there and
catch it no no p
e to go
all right
oh oh okay i did i got i got uh grappled
just lots of grapple shenanigans huh
never
i used them to kill the guys no no no no
no no that was spiteful that was
intentional you know it
i feel targeted
oh god that was a chief
yeah i gotta kill the bad guys i tagged
him too
just went full multiplayer mode shoot
that guy in the face
oh wow it's getting a little hectic i
that's the half the fun it is it's so
it's
more than half the phone yeah
yeah
we're all using that mango that we got
off that boss right yeah that's why
we're right here i don't have that one
i actually haven't mangled
don't use that that inferior version
i gotta challenge myself somehow ron
not me not me challenges but chumps
that's why i'm not playing a legendary
we're doing good on heroic it's not it's
just this is soft it's not really a
problem this is this
good catch oh man
i don't want to spoil legendary for
people who you know they out here ready
to play it well we you're just mad
because we told you no tank gun
i still have thoughts and i don't like
any of them
four tank guns would be something
oh gosh
never let me have any fun i love being
able to disrupt the shield jackals with
the grapple it just feels so dang good
oh yeah i forgot about that i forgot
about these invisible turkeys
come here
you know you over here stop being
shielded
oh isaac you're down huh
hold on oh oh stab me all the time
he's close i need some
i wasn't expecting that yeah i wasn't
either i tried all fun and games until a
cloak delete comes in i tried to rush
them
and see if i could have coiled them i
would have been no no issue no contest
look at me all weapons out of ammo again
i'm just overconfident from using the
death mode chiefs all the time you're
right
what's this reloading thing
nothing wrong in a little bottomless
clip debug menu option
oh man
you jumped on him right after i stuck a
plasma on him
oh god oh god several of you died mulkey
this is when the kids would say get good
i know right didn't you make the game
i started throwing a plasma i was nice
about it okay
i did not in fact oh you know come here
i'm getting revengeance
welcome thank you ron i baited him and
then bought him out into the open that
was my strategy the whole time thank you
did not escape
to save my life i would not do that i'm
a smart
oh yeah
here we go
let's open up the uh
hashes open hydrotubes oh wait no this
wasn't 100 tubes
that's a confirmed kill with the ravager
i want that to go on record okay yep oh
he's up avenge me yes we will
oh that was for you isaac thank you i
took the other guy's sword and used it
on his friend
oh there's another one do i want the
shotgun or ah but i don't want to lose
my shotgun i don't use my good mangler
either but i got a sword
pulling all the weapons
it's a hard choice you could drop one
for us to carry for you no i'll give it
back nah i um
i don't trust anybody in this party to
include myself
oh shoot oh this is uh i just oh what
happened sorry oh
you all that
we're good we're still in this i saw
multiple y'all go down let's finish this
fight ron
you know if we both die that we'll put
it into the fight that's true
oh man but now we're not going to do
that
or some other large cat
oh come on
is that what i've been doing to people i
call that the coil skull it's just
incoming incoming coils at any time
without warning
you better adapt
oh they stuck me
they stuck me i hated here guys one
thing it's pretty minor but we didn't
actually mention it specifically for
folks that maybe aren't aware is the all
of our the campaign uh co-op game right
now is running on one of our dedicated
servers right right in our data centers
yeah
yeah we always run on dedicated servers
no more
he was wearing some flair
stop killing people before i have a
chance put this plasma cannon on your
forehead
here you go
i only got a little splash damage thanks
man you're welcome
it's teamwork right there it is teamwork
makes a dream work
what makes us die much faster
you do not understand
oh i was the sores out of energy uh i
need a gun
get this man a weapon i'm gonna take a
spanker yeah
ron can you catch this uh he wants to
catch this coil okay hold on i'm nowhere
near y'all i'm i'm i'll try right now
here we go here we go i'll throw it at
you one of us will catch you i'm trying
i'm trying to travel you're going to
grapple
is that too slow i was too slow wasn't i
i think someone younger needs to do that
let ron try it i tried it and i also
failed i flung myself forward
so if i were to successfully do that
john does do i catch it or does it just
you can't explode in my face you grapple
it and it pulls it to you and then you
all right i got another one i got
another one so we can have it oh you
know something else we haven't touched
on yet either guys is uh my
understanding is uh when this feature
does eventually launch we will have a
host of brand new achievements added to
the game right we will for both uh co-op
and mission replay achievements for both
i don't quote me on this i want to say
it's
there's like eight to twelve new
achievements i i should have looked this
up before the stream ten i would have to
look i think it's 13 13 sure okay but
they're really fun they all sort of
promote co-op gameplay and extra
shenanigans is at least one of them coil
a homie
[Laughter]
we kind of stayed away from the uh the
griefing achievements okay fair enough
people like me do exist so there's that
ron i got a call i can throw at you if
you want to try to grab i have one that
i'm carrying around just for gp
oh i remember this mission i died
eleventy billion times in this room okay
so many times it was shock rifles all to
my left right shock rifle all day shock
rifle all night it was real bad
but i'm coming back with rockets and
this one once everything gets rolling is
really fun when you grab a coil and then
you go to these man cannons and you
this is taking longer than i thought
something is taking control of local
systems
in retrospect i do need to get sketched
back for that that uh
that coil he just blew smoove off my
hand
i did not appreciate that haha i tried
to help you i tried to shoot that guy i
was unsuccessful
is that what we're calling just because
i failed doesn't mean actually
i should be held accountable
look i tried it was a bonus that i was
trying to offer and you know you tried
yeah that's what counts the intent
reinforcements reinforced
bring them to the fight
shoot you four of us get a lot of arcing
electricity going if you wanted to huh
yes cool
if i could hit him oh god
all right this was
aha
i don't know ron i think you kind of
oversold how dangerous this this area
was hey
hey hey don't judge me all right it was
i was young and naive and i didn't know
what i was doing i just needed the right
team exactly you know and now i have
positive influences in my life and i'm
back on track i'm no longer a troubled
youth all right so it's good
these rooms are supposed to be easier as
you get older
sweet we did it i did nice job
wow that did go much faster than it did
if i can't
[Laughter]
oh my goodness why does everyone have
shock rifles i hate it
there's one on the ground right here you
could get
no no my all of my foes had shot rifles
that's the part that made me sad i'm
fine with me i interfaced with the
cradle it unlocked something
something important
cortana was here six months ago i could
feel what she felt when you arrived
it's fun
a thruster module evasive maneuvers on
demand
now then
well i don't know how far you guys want
to feel like going today it feels i mean
we could play all afternoon let's finish
the game it's probably someone just
straight through
get a legendary ending game's done slow
that's the thing right
i don't know if anybody wants to watch
it but i'm sure it is a thing
ron
i mean admittedly with the backlog that
i have i've been playing that particular
game for a while now
i do have collectibles and a couple
skulls to go back and pick up so i've
been looking forward to the replay
here's a couple things i need to go back
like so like i'm still missing fast
during the skull i really just kind of
got stuck
so i'm i'm looking forward to going back
yeah we never did get to do that um
i'm gonna take us someplace checkpoint
that the fob that isaac wanted to go in
yep we could do that i'm gonna i'm gonna
maybe do that and kind of
try to
rescue some fellow marines and
we'll wrap things up
we do a little uh vehicle stuff
i'm pretty sure at least one of the
achieve co-op achievements is a
vehicle-based achievement it's uh yeah
it's it's based on you know hanging out
the the the car window with the baseball
bat
hitting mailboxes uh only you're using a
gravity hammer and a warthog
i'm immature so that's funny right
right there with you
oh man
i should get a gun uh so let's uh let's
call in maybe a razorback
i kind of want to be a gunner okay let's
do that also there's four uh weapon
crates here so that everyone can select
their weapons simultaneously that's
right oh
look at that
and i want to get that
if you were ever wondering why there
were always four weapon crates at the
fobs
because it was preparing for co-op
i need to get that sweet sweet mangler
i'm going back to it as well
i'm doing the i'm doing the one that we
got off our boss that's
who's driving and who are we ditching oh
y'all some hateful y'all haters man
whatever i'm gonna get my own vehicle
hop in right now
hop
okay well
remember this remember how we died i'll
call in a goose i'll fall where are we
headed where are we going where you want
to go
well i thought we were rescuing the
marines
yeah go
is about to get dropped in your head
there no no no no i'm good i'm good i'm
good everything's good
oh time for a sweet jump no never mind
it's not a sweet jump at all
what's that okay that went real well
okay there's a road too
i warned y'all about this
first place all right get up get back in
here get back in here oh you're saying
i'm gonna get on i'm gonna i'm gonna oh
you're not riding with us yeah yeah you
guys go ahead whatever whatever we're
gonna go down this cliff face right here
okay
we're getting this sweet edge oh my gosh
this is great do it you can do it i mean
okay that's a tree hold on for suckers
yeah totally oh we're still on it we're
still on it you can do it here it
is all right
[Music]
yeah yeah buddy wait why are we getting
shot so viciously
i landed on the enemy pose okay
we got it we're
nice i'm hooked
i shoot coils too it's all good
oh that's a marine i shot that guy did
you get the gun anything
i feel like ron denied you your chance
to use that that turret i got a couple
guys on the way over okay exactly i was
i helped
i was there
oh that's also achieved i love the
subtitles angry electrocuted roar
[Laughter]
sweet
valor credit for that when we go back to
our individual saves as well nice
all right cool we did it
you guys want to just call it call it a
wrap right there anything else we
haven't touched on uh isaac or john that
you want to convey about this upcoming
flight
i think
we're good okay
i'm eager to play
yeah it's uh you know it's fun and stuff
that would do with that coil i finally
got them back
gotta have one last one last hurrah
well that was a quick look at halo
infinite's network co-op the flight
build which as we mentioned at the start
we are working through the certification
process right now we are hopeful that
the flight might still go out the door
and be live tomorrow
but we're kind of in a wait and see
approach as as that final pass continues
so best bet would just be to stay tuned
to halo social channels and of course
once we do have the all clear and ready
for takeoff uh we will get the word out
on social and you'll be able to find all
the information you need with
instructions to get the build on xbox or
steam
via the halo support site
you also want to keep an eye on your
halo waypoint messages as well so really
appreciate everyone's interest and
support who has opted in we can't wait
to get the flight in your hands
get a lot of great feedback and data
over to isaac and john and team as they
continue to polish and uh finalize this
feature
gentlemen any final parting words before
we uh shut it down for today just really
looking forward to getting it out there
can't wait for everyone to play
absolutely
we used a lot of coils today but
honestly friendly fire is serious
business so make sure you're watching
where your bullets go uh we had fun but
we're professionals and we never did
manage to catch a coil in midair but we
did not i want to i'm sure our feeds
will be full of that once this flight's
out the door so
uh again thank you all for joining us
today thanks everyone for your patience
we look forward to getting this flight
out to you soon also just a quick
reminder uh for multiplayer fans next
week on tuesday does mark the start of
our alpha pack event it's a continuation
of the season two narrative you'll want
to check that out there'll be some
updates i'm told coming to last spartan
standing
speaking of which too just a heads up i
think we're going to take last spartan
standing down out of matchmaking on
monday
just for the day and then it'll come
back on tuesday as part of the alpha
pack event
and the multiplayer team's been taking a
lot of feedback from the community and
you'll see some tweaks there and you'll
be able to find more information about
that soon on the hill support site so
i think that's it that's a wrap thanks
everyone sketch here on behalf of the
whole team thank you we'll see you
online soon have a great day